our primetime special that's right
primetime special Conan in Israel I
returned to my homeland is airing is a
herring next Tuesday I changed my name
to get make it in the business coated in
Israel is airing next Tuesday September
19th that's this coming Tuesday at 10
o'clock p.m. here on TBS and we had I
feel I went a thousand places I had a
thousand adventures and I just want to
show you just a brief tiny little
snippet while I was in Israel I decided
to go all-in and actually get bar
Mitzvahed yes
I'd never had a bar mitzvah and so I
wanted to get bar Mitzvahed at an
Orthodox synagogue with a very serious
rabbi I really did this and here's a
tiny little clip to give you just a peek
I feel I feel good do I look Jewish to
you it begins that's right okay by the
way I hate to break it to you but he's
reading The Da Vinci Code it's not as
farley as you think he loves it here
were just at the park now where they
escaped from the Louvre he was a
a lot of fascinating stuff - be sure to
watch our primetime special coder in
Israel airing next Tuesday September
19th at 10 o'clock p.m. and there are a
ton of extras so check out all the conan
in israel extras at team koco.com slash
israel because there's a lot of material
there all right so check it out
[Applause]
you